Hi I'm Ryan Beck and welcome
to IKEA furniture prescription
drug or Thai politician.
I'm going to say a word.
I know you're going
to let me know.
Is it a ikea furniture
a prescription drug
or a Thai politician.
Only I know and they're not
going to get it right.
Matt how do you even play this.
Are you ready. We're ready.
Wonderful. I've been preparing
for this my whole life.
Are you ready to go.
I feel like
you're showing me your cards
I didn't.
I'm going to shuffle it.
OK. Your first word
is your Jakafi, Jakafi.
That coffee and feel very ikea.
Like table-y.
Oh that's Ikea.
It's a prescription
drug my friend.
Yes it's a prescription
drug
it is indicated
for treatment of patients
with intermediate
or high risk milo fibrosis
oh me low fibrosis of course.
What's that. Google it.
Jakafi sounds
like something
I usually walk on walk in
on my boyfriend doing.
They just got it.
cuz they're dudes. Next word
Tarva.
Sounds like it could be
like a bookshelf.
Now this is the one
that sounds
the most like Ikea furniture.
But I feel like
I keep getting burnt with
these prescription medications.
I thought that was part
of a vagina.. that's a vulva
that's a vulva.. easily
confused. Tarva
Also the prime minister
of Thailand.
I'm worried that this game
is making me
seem racially insensitive
to South Asian peoples.
You're not the only one.
I think I've shattered a Tarva
that's an IKEA furniture.
That's correct.
Thats a six drawer chest.
it's as beautiful as it is
functional
I cut off the paper so
I can't read the rest of it.
I know for a fact is IKEA
furniture because I own one.
You own this wall lamp.
Yes. Retail's in $19.99.
So make sure to watch
his special $19.99 something
that everyone
who works here can afford.
When you make money
and you can afford it
then you should shop at Ikea
because it's a real trip.
I'm truly only sitting like this
because I want my shoe
in the shot Watana Watana.
Forever is a phrase
that just came to mind.
Going to see a politician.
You got it.
Politician Watana forever.
I love that guy voted
for him
a Minister of Social Development
and Human Security I'm a
Minister of human insecurity.
Did you know that
Thai Panther again
insensitive people
have been complaining
that this game is maybe
like culturally insensitive.
Yeah it might be.
Well you know at least they got
a straight host what a stupid
game
because you lost. Some would say
it's an expertly crafted game
thanks for playing.
That was IKEA furniture
prescription drug
or Thai politician.
Thanks for having me.
I was forced.